Race day. Your pulse pounds. Your head throbs.
Your adrenaline rushes.
The starting gun goes off and so do you—
into a wall of creeping runners.
That accordion-like crush of runners waiting
to get out of their starting corrals
intrigued scientists, who wondered if the movement
movement could be modeled.
To find out, they filmed thousands of runners from
high level balconies as they left the
starting corrals of several major marathons.
Scientists used an algorithm  to track the speed of
runners as they moved to the starting line.
When directed by race staffers, runners shuffled
forward several meters before stopping—
and starting up again.
The speed and density changed, and moved backward
through the pack of runners, like a wave.
The scientists discovered that the waves
move back at a constant rate, which means
that they can estimate how long it takes
for the change in speed to travel all
the way through the crowd.
The "faster" blocks were usually the same length as
the distance the race staffers moved
forward, each time they set out from a complete stop.
But, unlike the waves that traveled back through the racers,
no waves traveled from side-to-side,
despite imperfections in the crowd's movement.
This is one of the first studies to look at the physics of
human movement—not at the individual level,
but at the level of the whole crowd,
similar to previous studies in bacteria.
scientists say this research could be
helpful for crowd management or creating more
accurate visual effects of crowds in movies.
Their model of how waves of speed and density travel
through confined crowds could also lay the
foundation for understanding how crowds
respond to emergencies.
For now, it could help make your cue up to the starting
line a little bit smoother.